nach corona ausbrüchen der
fleischindustrie die bundesregierung
verbietet in dieser branche werkverträge
corona hilfe für lufthansa die
bundesregierung hat sich auf ein paket
zur unterstützung der airline geeinigt
bessere nahrungsmittel vom feld mit dem
green deal will die eu den dünger und
pestizideinsatz deutlich senken
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster die welt am mittwoch guten
abend und wir kommen bei den heute
-nachrichten die missstände in der
fleischindustrie mit miserablen
bedingungen für die menschen die dort
arbeiten sind schon lange bekannt
doch der massenhafte ausbruch des corona
virus in einigen betrieben hat nun die
bundesregierung veranlasst konsequent zu
handeln
ab januar 21 werden leiharbeit und
verschachtelte sub unternehmer
strukturen verboten
wie viele ausländische hilfskräfte in
der deutschen fleischindustrie arbeiten
lässt sich nicht genau sagen
die branche hält sich da bedeckt sicher
ist sie werden ausgebeutet
oft kommen die helfer aus osteuropa
arbeiten nicht direkt für die
schlachthöfe sondern für sub unternehmer
und das zu dumpinglöhnen viele von ihnen
sind in engen sammelunterkünften
untergebracht was sich jetzt ändern soll
dazu florian a das osteuropäische
arbeiter in deutschen fleischfabriken
ausgebeutet werden oder dass sie in
massenunterkünften wie diesen hausen
müssen ist eigentlich seit jahren
bekannt zum großen thema aber wurde es
erst nach hunderten corona infektionen
in der fleischindustrie
wir erleben dass verhältnisse die vor
corona ständig in ordnung waren in
dieser krise zu einem besonderen problem
werden
das betrifft vor allen dingen das
massive infektionsgeschehen in fleisch
betrieben in fleischfabriken in der
republik frühere gesetzesverschärfungen
so der arbeitsminister seien oft von der
branche unterlaufen worden nun also
corona bedingt ein neuer versuch das
kabinett beschließt eckpunkte mit
möglichen neuen regeln für die
fleischindustrie ab 2021 sollen
werkverträge demnach verboten werden
damit fabriken die verantwortung für
missstände nicht mehr von sich weisen
können
außerdem geplant häufigere kontrollen
und bei arbeitszeit verstößen höhere
bußgelder auf das mögliche aus für die
leiharbeit reagiert die branche mit
einer drogen wuerde man es hier schlank
verbieten müssten wir mit unseren
standorten wahrscheinlich abwandern
ausnahmsweise lob dagegen von linker und
grünen opposition das geplante verbot
sei längst überfällig
nur dass es dabei nicht bleiben so
fordern die grünen weiterhin an den
mindestpreis für fleisch die
bundesregierung hat sich nur auf die
bedingungen in den schlachthöfen
konzentriert sie hasst das system des
billiger und mehr nicht angegriffen
angegriffen wird jetzt erst einmal das
arbeitsmodell der fleischindustrie die
eckpunkte von heute aber sind nur ein
erster schritt jetzt soll ein
gesetzentwurf folgen
den wiederum der bundestag beraten und
beschließen muss die lufthansa ist in
der korona krise ja tief in die roten
zahlen geraten der staat sollte helfen
doch wie genau darüber war sich die
bundesregierung uneinig jetzt scheint es
aber eine lösung zu geben berichten
verschiedene medien
wegen der pandemie und stehen damit
einhergehenden reisebeschränkungen hat
die lufthansa derzeit mehr als 90
prozent ihrer maschinen am boden
für das unternehmen bedeutet das einen
verlust von einer million euro pro
stunde
noch ist offen wie diese mögliche
einigung im detail aussieht deshalb
fragen wir theo koll in berlin tu was
hören sie über das paket das davon
bundesregierung und lufthansa geschnürt
wurde nur auf dem paket so jedenfalls
die medienberichte soll stehen 25
prozent plus einer aktie das heißt der
bund würde mit dieser beteiligung gut
ein viertel der wirtschaftlich schwer
angeschlagenen lufthansa kaufen
die kosten werden mit rund neun
milliarden beziffert damit hätte der
bund dann künftig eine sogenannte
sperrminorität das heißt er könnte zwei
aufsichtsräte besetzen und bei der
lufthansa mit entscheiden
genau darüber hatte es hier heftigen
streit in der koalition gegeben teile
der union wollten ja nur eine stille
beteiligung der staat sei einfach kein
guter unternehmer die spd fraktion
dagegen drängte auf eine aktivere
mitbestimmung wenn man denn schon soviel
geld gibt dann wolle man auch mit
entscheiden beispielsweise über den
künftigen ökologischen kurs der
fluglinie eine so deutliche beteiligung
müsste dann mit zweidrittelmehrheit
einer außerordentlichen hauptversammlung
entschieden werden die braucht vier
wochen einladungsfrist und bis dahin
verliert die lufthansa weiterhin sie
haben sie eben gesagt stündlich eine
million euro
die kanzlerin hat vor wenigen minuten
bestätigt man sei in intensiven
gesprächen und in kürze sei mit einer
entscheidung zu rechnen
vielen dank für die erläuterung theo
koll in berlin
und auch das hat das kabinett
beschlossen der staat soll künftig ein
mitspracherecht haben wenn investoren
von außerhalb der eu bei unternehmen im
gesundheitssektor einsteigen etwa bei
herstellern von schutzkleidung und
medizingeräten und die lohnfortzahlung
für eltern wird verlängert wenn sie
nicht arbeiten gehen können weil wegen
corona kindergärten oder schulen
geschlossen sind bekommen sie jeweils
zehn statt bisher sechs wochen lang etwa
zwei drittel ihres gehalts gezahlt
alleinerziehende bis zu 20 wochen die
lohnfortzahlungen mag familien in dieser
zeit etwas helfen ändert aber nichts an
dem traurigen befund vieler kinderärzte
derzeit weil die kita so lange
geschlossen sind und die kinder zuhause
bleiben haben misshandlungen zugenommen
vor allem bei den ganz kleinen
kinderschützer sind sehr besorgt über
die zunehmende gewalt in den familien
strohmann leskovar röntgenbilder die
ärzte im bereich kinderschutz immer
wieder sehen arm und beinbrüche
rippenfrakturen oliver berthold berät
bei verdachtsfällen ärzte
rettungssanitäter bei der medizinischen
kinderschutzhotline riefen in den ersten
maiwochen so viele ratsuchende an wie im
gesamten april die korona krise für
familien offenbar eine belastung
wir haben jetzt in der ersten maihälfte
rund 50 fälle beraten in denen es auch
um diese schweren verletzungen ging was
eben insbesondere bei kleinen kindern
per se schon misshandlungs verdächtig
sein kann weil diese kinder nicht am
straßenverkehr teilnehmen oder oder in
den sportverein gehen wo sind diese
verletzung sonst auftreten können die
starken einschränkungen belasten auch
die familienhilfe hatten experten früh
gewarnt für mitarbeiter sei es teils
schwierig kontakt zu halten durch schul
und kita schließungen fiel ein
warnsystem aus der kinderschutzbund
macht daher ähnliche beobachtungen wir
haben nur eindrücke aus gesprächen mit
jugendamts mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern
dort war es so dass im märz und april
die zahlen stark abgenommen haben und
jetzt im mai sank wieder steigen das
familienministerium sieht die gefahr
dass kinder zeitweise ins dunkelfeld
geraten sind umso wichtiger bestimmte
einschränkungen jetzt wieder zu lockern
das bedeutet dass es auch aus kindeswohl
und kinderschutz aspekte neben zu
befürworten ist wenn die kitas und auch
die schulen jetzt weiter öffnen aber wir
müssen und ich sage es nochmal gewiss
nicht immer sehen auch vor dem
infektionsgeschehen die medizinische
kinderschutzhotline hofft deshalb dass
die eigenen zahlen eine momentaufnahme
bleiben durch mehr unterstützung die
anrufe wieder weniger werden
ein blick auf die aktuellen corona daten
für deutschland zeigt die zahl der
täglichen neuinfektion ist wieder leicht
gestiegen im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage haben sich 660
menschen täglich neu angesteckt die
johns hopkins universität hat seit
ausbruch der pandemie gut 178 1000
infizierte registriert davon gelten
knapp 157 1000 als genesen 8100 36
menschen sind in verbindung mit cupid 19
gestorben
und jetzt zu ganz anderen zahlen diese
virus krise corona kostet uns alle auch
viel geld
bund länder und kommunen haben deutlich
weniger einnahmen und schnüren
gleichzeitig enorme hilfspakete heißt am
ende die schulden wachsen
beispiele dass finanzstarke bayern nimmt
für seinen anti corona von 20 milliarden
euro auf die finanzschwachen bremer 1,2
milliarden keine klatsche die details
warten auf bessere zeiten wie der
besatzung des kreuzfahrtschiffes geht es
momentan vielen der hafenumschlag als
konjunkturbarometer
bei autos etwa ging es um 30 prozent
bergab
die flaute erwischt doch den
hafenbetreiber die bremer
lagerhausgesellschaft wir haben über das
ganze unternehmen außerdem mit rund
12.000 beschäftigten in deutschland
haben wir im moment eine
durchschnittliche kurzarbeit von knapp
unter 30 prozent
wir werden ein wie alle unternehmen
glaube ich oder die meisten ziemlich
desaströses ergebnis für das jahr 2020
zu verarbeiten haben
mittendrin das land bremen als
anteilseigner des hafens zudem massive
ausfälle bei der gewerbesteuer um den
finanziellen corona kollaps zu
verhindern der plan ein 1,2 milliarden
schweres hilfspaket
doch wie finanziert das kleinste
bundesland den sogenannten bremen vor
man kann sich überlegen dass die länder
und der bund vielleicht auch die
kommunen da wo sie betroffen sind
gemeinsam kredite aufnehmen warum der
bund hat günstigere zinskonditionen noch
als die länder
da ist noch ein unterschied von 0,3
prozent ungefähr kann man indem man sich
zusammentut letztlich noch günstigere
zinsen erzielen diesen gemeinsamen weg
gehen andere länder bisher ab bayern ist
gegen eine vergemeinschaftung von
schulden
das ist eine ganz wichtige botschaft für
uns und wir wollen nicht haben dass
diejenigen bestraft werden die in den
letzten jahren gut gewirtschaftet haben
was bayern stattdessen favorisiert
bundesmittel für gezielte landes
projekte einzusetzen wie etwa die
digitalisierung ländlicher regionen
wegen der korona pandemie werden jetzt
auch blutkonserven knapp das rote kreuz
warnt in einigen bundesländern reichen
die vorräte nicht einmal für einen tag
etwa in baden württemberg und hessen
eine notsituation sei das aber noch
nicht
die bereitschaft blut zu spenden sei
immer noch hoch es gebe aber weniger
möglichkeiten dazu weil termine an
universitäten oder in unternehmen wegen
der korona sich
als maßnahmen der zeit wegfallen
erinnern sie sich noch an das absolute
top thema der eu kommission vor corona
der green deal ein plan für mehr
naturschutz und gegen den klimawandel
heute hat die kommission konkrete ziele
genannt demnach sollen 30 prozent aller
land und meeresflächen zu schutzgebieten
werden
die bauern sollen 50 prozent weniger
pestizide einsetzen und mindestens 20
prozent weniger dünger und ein viertel
aller anbauflächen soll biologisch
bewirtschaftet werden elisabeth schmidt
berichtet boden sensoren und
satellitendaten zeigen landwirt kaspar
halle wo er düngemittel einsparen kann
feldversuche in niedersachsen und wenn
es nach der eu-kommission geht die
landwirtschaft zukunft was die absoluten
zahlen angeht bin ich der überzeugung
dass wir bei den 20 prozent dünner
einsparungen und den 50 prozent
pflanzenschutz einsparungen
mittelfristig schon technologische
lösungen dafür haben aber es ist ein
ambitioniertes ziel
und es bedeutet sehr viel veränderung
nur noch halb so viele antibiotika in
der tierhaltung ein viertel mehr
bioanbau mehr naturschutzflächen zehn
jahren rissel dafür zeit geben kritik
wir haben die große sorge dass über die
farm sofort strategie ist zu einer
auslagerung der landwirtschaftlichen
erzeugung aus europa heraus in
drittstaaten kommt beispielsweise nach
südamerika nach brasilien
doch die eu-kommission hat
nachhaltigkeit und affen schutz zur
überlebensstrategie erklärt bayerischen
biodiversitätsstrategie ist notwendig
damit wir das auftreten und die
verbreitung von krankheiten künftig
verhindern können
rund eine million arten sind europaweit
vom aussterben bedroht dadurch bringen
wir unser eigenes leben unsere
gesundheit und unseren wohlstand in
gefahr
wie luck dazu kommt heute von den grünen
allerdings strategie kann man lachen und
abheften da folgt noch gar nichts raus
sie muss jetzt im rechtsnormen umgesetzt
werden die eu kommission hat heute ziele
vorgegeben konkrete gesetze zur
umsetzung für die landwirte fehlen noch
vw hat sich rassismus-vorwürfe
eingehandelt mit einem werbespot für den
neuen golf gepostet auf instagram zu
sehen sind neben dem auto ein mann mit
dunkler hautfarbe der von einer weißen
hand weg geschnitzt wird
vw hat sich entschuldigt nennt den clip
geschmacklos und will das aufklären
der chef des betriebsrats osterloh sagt
er schäme sich für diesen spot peter
kunst berichtet nicht lustig ein
fehlgriff ganz und gar eine weiße hand
manövriert in einem werbevideo für den
neuen golf einen schwarzen mann an den
rand und schnitzt ihn dann weg rassismus
ganz offensichtlich und offiziell auf
dem instagram account von volkswagen bis
der konzerne mit dem beginn des sturms
dagegen wieder löschte die reaktion von
volkswagen wir können die empörung und
wut als reaktion verstehen ganz ohne
frage das video ist falsch und
geschmacklos wir werden aufklären wie
das passieren konnte und konsequenzen
daraus ziehen
ein geschmackloser scherz vielleicht
sogar mehr stoppt man das instagram
filmchen dann liest man [ __ ] und die
weiße hand formt sich zudem zeichen mit
dem sich die rassistische amerikanische
white supremacy bewegung grüßt
volkswagen hatte eine erste reaktion auf
seinem instagram account gelöscht
da stand die gezeigten inhalte stellen
einen kreativen umgang mit dem format
instagram story dar
kommerzielle kreativität die grenzen
verletzt in sozialen medien nicht selten
aber dass volkswagen video war da schon
viral das internet verzeiht nichts wer
hat das gepostet wer hat es abgenommen
volkswagen sucht noch nach antworten
in der korona krise leiden nicht nur die
fluggesellschaften sondern auch die
flughäfen
nun soll der wichtigste airport der
deutschen hauptstadt schließen berlin
tegel an dem innenstadtnahen flughafen
werden vom 15 juni an keine maschinen
mehr starten oder landen sei denn die
passagierzahlen erholen sich noch einmal
deutlich
markus gross über einen dann wohl
vorzeitigen abschied für immer nichts
mehr los in tegel kaum noch passagiere
kaum noch abflüge seit wochen schon und
das corona virus hat auch den
flugverkehr hart getroffen
7 millionen euro verlust pro monat zu
viel für die flughafenbetreiber tegel
soll vorübergehend vom netz mitte juni
ist hier schluss schon jetzt abschied
und wehmut sehr schade weil große
emotionale erinnerungen an dem flughafen
hängen uns natürlich auch in flughafen
der kurzen wege gewesen
1974 ein neuer flughafen für die
inselstadt west berlin
der markante sechseckige bau ein echter
hingucker
historisch der erste lufthansa flug am
tag vor der wiedervereinigung danach
einfallstor für weltmeister und
weltenlenker doch schon bald zu klein zu
voll zu laut tegel schon lange nicht
mehr zeitgemäß und jetzt auch noch
corona
es sind jetzt auch eher wirtschaftliche
gründe die da im vordergrund stehen das
muss man ganz klar sagen nur noch ein
prozent des sonst bewältigten
fluggastaufkommen es wird im moment in
tegel abgefertigt nun soll der rest
flugverkehr komplett nach schönefeld bis
der br im oktober auf macht für tegel
sind die tage gezählt der flughafen
schließt am 15 juni wohl für immer
stück für stück kehrt das land zurück in
richtung normalität
jetzt ein weiterer schritt in den ersten
bundesländern dürfen freibäder wieder
öffnen
unbeschwertes badevergnügen wie wir es
alle kennen wird es aber erst mal nicht
geben denn auch im wasser gelten die
abstandsregeln für die bäder heißt das
sie müssen die besucherzahlen begrenzen
freibad in corona zeiten wie das klappt
haben sich peter böhme und pamela seidel
in nordrhein-westfalen angeschaut wie
sonnenaufgang gegen halb sechs und fast
schon völkerwanderung in düsseldorf das
erste freibad macht auf vorfreude also
zwei monate ohne schwimmen geht
überhaupt gar nicht wir sind ganz jahres
eine form ist wahrscheinlich komplett im
eimer
das wird schwierig und das schwimmen
muss man mal gucken also wie sich die
leute da arrangieren und wie das
funktioniert
jeder schwimmer muss sich hier vorher
online anmelden für ein bestimmtes
zeitfenster so wird die schwimmer zahl
im bad reguliert per handy code geht's
ins band dort wird dauert es infiziert
waren schwimmen selbst autobahnen mit
rechtsverkehr und breiter überholspur
das funktioniert sich im wasser mit
krone anzustecken ist kaum möglich das
chlor tötet die wiehre abstand ist
überall das gebot um 10 duschen pipi
machen alles mit distanz und fürs
personal diesbezüglich ganz wichtig die
schwimmnudeln die hat jetzt
zufälligerweise einem maß von 158 und
hilft natürlich den fachangestellten den
schwimmmeistern noch mal darauf
hinzuweisen bitte leute das ist der
abstand den haltet ihr bitte auch im
wasser ein
endlich wieder schwimmen dem corona
virus ein stückchen lebensqualität
abgetrotzt
zum sport und da gibt es eine wichtige
personalie bei der bundesliga
tabellenführer bayern münchen torwart
manuel neuer hat seinen vertrag
vorzeitig um zwei jahre verlängert
bis zum 30 juni 2023 wird der 34 jahre
alte nationaltorhüter nun in münchen
bleiben
ein monatelanges tauziehen um die dauer
des vertrages ist damit beendet
trainer hansi flick erklärt neuer auch
für die kommende saison zur klaren
nummer 1 und am freitag geht es in der
bundesliga mit dem hauptstadt-derby
weiter härter gegen union
der elfte gegen den zwölften mit dem
heimvorteil ist dass er bei
geisterspielen so eine sache
über das berliner duell peter leissl
blau weiße hertha gegen rot weiße
union-fans das olympiastadion wäre ohne
corona aus allen nähten geplatzt wird
sich am freitag aber doch nur so
präsentieren als leere betonschüssel
spielen ja jetzt auch darum dass wir
wieder irgendwann die zuschauer auch
wieder bei uns haben trainern aber die
hat die gelähmt wirkte der härter
reanimiert der drei zu null erfolg in
hoffenheim ein indiz die spieler setzten
sich jedoch in ihrem freudentaumel über
die hygiene regeln hinweg als einziger
bundesliga klubs passte leider ins bild
nach den instinkt losen handy aufnahmen
von kalu in den kabinen
tabellennachbar union kassierte gegen
bayern münchen eine heimniederlage unter
der fehlenden präsenz der fans scheint
der verein aus köpenick besonders zu
leiden
und wir haben noch die lottozahlen die
gewinnzahlen lauten 9 31 33 42 45 49 und
die superzahl 1 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 5 57 zum wetter da
steht uns morgen noch ein sonniger
warmer tag bevor aber schauer und
gewitter warten schon in den kulissen
mehr dazu gleich von beste interne das
war es von uns schön dass sie dabei war
das heute schon mit claus kleber heute
etwas später um kurz nach 10 und morgen
an christi himmelfahrt sind wir auch
wieder für sie da punkt 19 uhr einen
entspannten abend wünsch ich schiss
eine gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die nächsten schauer und gewitter
sie erreichen uns dann erst am freitag
mit diesem tieferes schiebt dann seine
kaltfront einmal über deutschland hinweg
aber sehen hier den roten fall da kommt
noch warme luft vorher zu uns und die
temperaturen steigen kräftig an
in der nacht gibt es im osten mehr
wolken als im westen und es wird trocken
bleiben bei temperaturen von drei bis
vier grad an oder und neiße 12 bis 13
grad am main und am rhein
und morgen viel sonnenschein vor allem
im südwesten wieder
ansonsten sind harmlose wolken unterwegs
meist kumuluswolken und da fällt auch
keinen regen raus und die temperaturen
erreichen 16 grad an der ostsee 19 an
der neiße und 29 grad im westen hier
generell wärmer und deutlich über 25
grad
die nächsten tage am freitag im norden
schauer und gewitter die reinziehen bis
29 grad warm und samstag und sonntag
dann kühler und schauer und gewitter ein
schöner abend